وعلى الارض وفي وقت تامل فيه اوكرانيا
ترتيب صفوفها طبعا لبدء هجوم مضاد يتوقع
ان يكون في الربيع المقبل لجات القوات
الروسيه الى استراتيجيه الارض المحروقه في
مدينه باخمت المحاصره شرقي البلاد بحسب
الجيش الاوكراني فان القوات الروسيه تعمد
الى تدمير المباني وايضا المواقع بضربات
جويه واخرى مدفعيه جدير بالذكر ان سياسه
الارض المحروقه هي استراتيجيه عسكريه او
طريقه عمليات يتم فيها احراق اي شيء قد
يستفيد منه العدو عند التقدم او التراجع
في منطقه ما لكن
وهو قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه قال ان
القوات الروسيه تحولت الى تكتيكات الارض
المحروقه التي استخدمت واستخدمتها في
سوريا قبل سنوات مؤكدا ان قوته لا تزال
صامده في الدفاع عن المدينه رغم اقراره
بصعوبه الوضع قال ان روسيا ترسل قوات خاصه
ووحدات هجوميه محموله جوا للمساعده في
هجومها على المدينه بعدما اصاب الانهاك
عناصر مجموعه فاغنر
ها هي مدينتنا يتم تحريرها على العدو لا
يرحم المدينه ولا مقاتليه ويدفع بهم الى
المطحنه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات